fred is with us in Los Angeles hi Fred
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up yeah good so here's a question my
wife and I all of your planned and
thankful are with debt we both are
college educated make over two thousand
dollars a year and then other part of
the coin is my parents while they are
also very wealthy and helped us not pay
off our debt so much as to helped us get
a home when the economy's in the
downturn and be able to get in some
places so they did help make a down
payment on our house so outside of that
we're in a pretty good spot I guess oh
we've completed the steps and my god I'm
just putting money away and whatnot by
God reason why I call this some time
maybe some someone's kind of like your
daughter goes through I'm guessing being
connected to you finding that a lot of
our friends a lot maybe four or five are
envious of our situation and what are
the piers would be is that my parents
have given us money to live the kind of
lifestyle that we have we don't oh you
know over live our money as the Bible
teaches and we give and we're very
generous or giving buy so we do make you
some amount of money but again it goes
back to I had friends make comments very
excited comment about oh wow it must be
nice or things of that nature and it's
just it's tough to hear that because
when my friends have good things happen
to them I'm generally happy for them
I've happy that they're doing wow that
they've got a good job and been able to
buy a house and I'm really happy for
that but it just feels like sometimes
some people are your friends are jealous
or antia so yeah it's really you're in
how old are you 35 okay well you're old
enough that you've experienced that some
of the people you went to high school
with you're no longer in contact with
because you're anything in common with
them right yeah I do
my high school because you're stuck but
because you don't have anything in
common with them right I mean the people
I used to raise hell with when I quit
raising hell and I mean anything in
common with them you know and so I mean
I'm not mad at them I'm happy to spend
time with them but they're probably not
going to be in my inner circle like they
were when I was in high school because
we they've continued that lifestyle and
I haven't okay right and so what happens
as you become more successful regardless
of how you did it as long as you did it
legally and morally and ethically which
obviously you did but as you become more
successful there are people that don't
understand and they make hurtful or
snide comments sometimes they're even in
your family and so what Sharon and I
have learned to do is we have to decide
how hurtful and how close that person is
if this is a distant person who just
says something that's you know just
socially weird and they they're just too
dumb to know that what they said was
hurtful
we just water off a duck's back and let
it go but if this was what we consider
to be a close friend who made a comment
like that I would call them out on it
and I would say listen you know what
number one you're wrong
number two that's hurtful you act like
with your little eye roll and it must be
nice that I haven't done this and this
somehow that my parents did it for me
our parents helped us but it was very
little dude I make a couple of hundred a
year and we've managed to live on less
than that because we're disciplined and
that's how we got where we were look had
nothing to do with it and so if you and
I are gonna be friends you're gonna have
to be my cheerleader not by a detractor
and I've called people out on it sounds
just like that
but not many times most of the time
they're distant enough from me and I
just don't really care what they think
and so I just go on you know we built a
big nice house and you know we had a you
know a person in the outer rings make
comments about our house you know oh
that's you shouldn't be doing a house
like that and you shouldn't that's just
opulent and they're just showing off or
whatever well all that means is I'm not
going to be spending time with you much
and I'm not gonna be I'm not going to
confront that person their four or five
rings outside the inner circle but if
they're close enough to me and they make
a comment like that I'll pop them a
little bit you know I'll call them out
on it
I mean gently but very firmly you know
I'm saying so you just decided right
which they are to use to whether you
want to bother with that or not my
question mill on that then is how
specific then do you get less them about
your situation obviously you know it's
indifference and I have but as far as
you know numbers go over hey you know
here's how it worked out or whatever
that's another business I you know you
can decide that in this situation but uh
you know I don't have to explain it to
you but I'm gonna tell you this much
okay here's what happened and you know
Mom and Dad helped us a little bit with
the house and everything else we did
because we make a couple hundred a year
and we live on less than we make it's
been a matter of discipline and
diligence and and do don't make a
comment like that again if you want to
be close with me because that's just
that makes me madder hurts my feelings
have you
last question kind of on same topic is
kind of going on what's your what's your
framework says and I agree that you keep
your friends close to you Zucotti sure
that's thing about income and I do have
some friends that are pretty close mad
that have also made somewhat similar
comments have you have the fandom is
that yeah yeah
sometimes it's affected by that now I've
got lots of friends that make a lot more
than I do and are a lot wealthier than I
am
and I got lots of friends that don't
have a small percentage of what we've
got and but there are the kinds of
people that I share a value system with
I share a faith walk with and what my
net worth or my income is irrelevant in
that relationship and if they can't if
they make it relevant by doing something
like that in that relationship it
damages the relationship I didn't change
I didn't become snobbish I'm still just
Dave from Antioch I'm still the same guy
I didn't change now I've cleaned up my
life as I've cleaned up my spiritual
walk over the last 40 years and you know
I'm a better person of character than I
was because I was a character you know
and so that that part has changed but
I'm saying I'm not I didn't become stuck
up or snobbish or I don't look down at
people because of money but I'm also not
gonna be talked down to by people who
purport to care about me because I've
become successful so you know I'm not
rub your nose in it and but you know
we're just not gonna have weirdness
around the money subject if we're gonna
have weirdness around the money subject
then then it's not gonna be happening
much if we're not gonna be around each
other much that's what it comes down to